if you're willing to accept as pretty
much anybody in the field of philosophy
of mine does that there are levels of
consciousness below human consciousness
then it's just
an assertion without evidence that there
can't be anything above yeah no you're
right it's also because you know this
Agency on yourself like it's like you
can notice that there are things acting
on you and that are constraining you and
that are directing your your movements
and your attention so it's like well why
wouldn't that why wouldn't I use the
same structure I've been using all the
way down to now explain what's above
let's say I don't know
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everybody I am very excited and
happy to be back with Father Stephen
DeYoung we've been trying to get to
talking for a while but it was always
being put back but I'm excited that it
finally happened and most of you
watching this know father Stephen he is
a priest in the Orthodox Church he's
also the host of The Lord of spirits
which is a podcast most of you that are
watching this will also know about he's
also written several books which I have
here great books religion of the
Apostles which uh which I was able to
read before and and give my my opinion
on he he published God is a man of war
which I'm reading right now and the
whole Council of God and introduction to
your Bible and so you've been extremely
prolific father it's crazy I know I
think it's because you don't sleep
that's what I that's the Legends we hear
Yeah well yeah I don't sleep much
it is true that part of it is that I
don't sleep much but I do sleep some
and so how how have you what did you
think about the success of the Lord of
Spirits because it's been a wild ride I
the the fans of Lord of spirits are
really into it and and it's it's
wonderful to see yeah yeah it's
um I mean
Father Andrew and I were aware that
there would be an audience for it
um I think at first when we talked to
ancient Faith radio they were not as
sure as we were that there was an
audience for it they thought it was
going to be kind of a little niche thing
maybe
um
but there's a much bigger there's been a
much bigger audience for it uh than I
initially thought and we've had people
from
all different Christian traditions
non-christians
listening to it uh some people who I I
never suspected would be endorsing and
promoting a podcast of mine
endorsing and promoting it in various
places
um
so yeah it's it's been pretty big but
I think
um even though it's different than a lot
of things on Ancient Faith radio and
different than just a lot of in general
sort of
religious podcasts I think it's
addressing things
the people have been at least aware of
it's sort of the the fringes right of
their ideas
right and it's sort of taking those
those ideas seriously
and sort of connecting them
in a way that I think is I think that's
what's attracting people I I don't think
it's adults at tones of my voice or
I'm sure it's some of that and also your
culture your cultural references yes I
think it's a there's a Zeitgeist there's
a moment I think also there's a strange
some of it I don't think anybody
controls would feels like the
materialism that was ruling just maybe
12 years ago or maybe 15 years ago
they're really harsh kind of new atheist
material has been broken
and and now people are scrambling to
figure out and it's as if there's a
space in their mind now to understand
ideas that would have seemed completely
ridiculous to them such as the idea of
agency above humans the notion of these
patterns and the fact that these
patterns are have a kind of agency uh on
on phenomena like all of these types of
of thinking is something that
for most people I know because I can see
it people are surprised at themselves
and they're like I I never thought I
would be able to under believe this but
it's also because they did understand it
um and so I don't know if you noticed
that as well yeah I mean I have and and
it was kind of inevitable because that
hard materialist View
has a real contradiction at its core
that eventually was going to break it
because for example the new atheist
would be all about materialism but then
when they gave an account of history and
particularly the history of religion
they have religion with agency
right religion caused people to do this
religion caused people to do all these
atrocious things religion cause it's
like well wait a minute hold on right
religious ideas right it's not a thing
that exists right and so
if there is this agent called religion
in history right I mean you could call
that God right like that
it's it's not just humans it's it's
causing humans to do things and so that
basic contradiction meant
you had to you had to accept the
antithesis of their presupposition in
order to accept their presupposition
yeah yeah well there's so many blind
spots in the new atheist thinking you
know just in terms in terms of the way
in which they get to their value system
or the way they they pretend like they
don't have hierarchies but then as soon
as soon as they blink they're back into
into these these hierarchies their own
hierarchies it's it it's actually
astounding to watch and it's difficult
for people that are still in that mode
to point it out because it's a blind
spot they can't see it as you you point
to it but it's as if they they don't
know what you're pointing at
yeah yeah and it's
you really have to push like that
contradiction I pointed out you have to
push on their own terms a lot of times
we've opposed people with those ideas by
just loudly applying the other idea
right or arguing for the other idea as
opposed to showing
okay let's take your idea seriously what
you're telling me and follow through on
it and does that actually work right
like where where does that end up is it
end up someplace self-contradictory
right and and then it sort of you know
say Boniface chopping down the tree
right it's like you may not believe my
religion but yours clearly has just
Fallen apart right
alternative right yeah definitely
there's also there's also something else
um
there's something else interesting
because as people are studying now the
question of Consciousness and of agency
and all of these issues are becoming
coming to the fore in terms of of trying
to figure out you know how what's the
relationship between science and and
human perception all of these questions
uh
people end up in a strange position as
well where all of a sudden now it's the
materialist or the naturalist that is
reducing agency and conscious and
self-consciousness at least
to humans
and so humans become this extremely
particular thing in the entire universe
that they can perceive this like
wonderfully completely anomalous thing
and also happened to be the strange
anomalous thing out of which all meaning
is is see coalescing towards and so it's
almost it's it's without knowing it it's
very religious although it's a
humanistic religion uh whereas the way
we we try to posit it is to say no these
there's a scale and there are
consciousnesses and and agencies that
exist at different levels
that seems that even in naturalist even
in the naturalistic point of view it
seems more reasonable that that would be
the case yeah they're having to revert
to a much earlier
version of the philosophy of mind right
they're having to go back to
like Hegel saying that animals are
basically just Little Machines right
yeah process inputs and like they don't
have any kind of awareness they don't
have any kind of you know
um and philosophy of mind has gotten way
past that I mean I I reference Nagel's
paper all the time on Lord of spirits
what is it like to be a bat right but
we just kind of say for it's like
something to be a bat
right yeah and that means there's some
kind of Consciousness there
right and if you're willing to accept as
pretty much anybody in the field of
philosophy of mine does that there are
levels of consciousness below human
consciousness
then it's just
an assertion without evidence that there
can't be anything above yeah no you're
right it's and also because you know
this Agency on yourself like it's like
you can notice that there are things
acting on you that are constraining you
and that are directing your your
movement and your attention attention so
it's like well why wouldn't that why
wouldn't I use the same structure I've
been using all the way down to now
explain what's above let's say I don't
know right right and and
um
yeah part of it I think is
a Devotion to a particular understanding
of freedom and free will
um that and and that's deeply tied into
Western theological Notions of guilt
and choice and accountability right and
the whole Western view of sin as being
purely transgression
right and so if the more you say a
person's choices are affected by things
greater than them
right forces sort of above them then
that if you have those presuppositions
means well that makes them less
accountable for their actions
right and and we're not gonna be able to
then ascribe guilt
right the person for action and so those
constructs are falling apart but you
don't necessarily need those other
constructs right
um especially in a Christian context
yeah right where in a Christian context
where we're not about assessing who is a
a good guy and who is a bad guy as much
as that's in grade in our culture right
and every Marvel movie is the good guy
the bad guy right and the good guy wins
yeah
um
right but we're about uh trying to help
redeem people from those forces right
Christianity has always taught this
there are these forces abroad in the
world they enslaved people
right they get they people get locked
into and controlled by these passions
and we're trying to free them from that
not hold them accountable for their
actions right like in this guilt and
Punishment sense
yeah
I wanna the the biggest reason why I had
I had you here was because I wanted to
talk a bit about the image of the son of
man it's one that I've been bringing up
more and more in my talks I've been I've
been kind of alluding to it as a
possible way to help people even secular
people understand the relationship what
man means or what what is it that The
Heavenly Man could be so I know that
you've studied that quite a bit in terms
of also understanding it's how it leads
into or it's a it's a kind of hint of
trinitarian theology in the Old
Testament so maybe you can you can kind
of take us through the line of these
these glimpses in the Old Testament and
how they ultimately lead to the
Incarnation yeah yeah so probably
I'll have to couch this a little and
people be familiar with this who Listen
to Lord of spirits but if you haven't
this is one of the most shocking things
I say right which
the idea of a god having multiple
hypostasis
is not original to the doctrine of the
trinity
this was commonly held by every culture
in the ancient world
[Music]
right they they understood that and in
fact
for them the the number of hypostasis
the number of embodiments or
localizations or whatever term you want
to use in English right of that God was
potentially infinite yeah you could make
one that's what idolatry is right you're
making one
right in this particular place for this
God
and you know the ancient Egyptians
noticed that when they were worshiping
Rey in his Temple at the idol the sun
did not disappear from the sky
right so they they understood that there
were multiple sort of coexisting
localizations of this one God
right so uh
the doctrine of the Trinity is a
particular
teaching regarding this that
The God Who created the universe that
God has three hypostasis right exists
eternally in three hypostasis and always
and only three you can't make more you
can't right even though the Israelites
tried with golden calves and other
things right
um
so uh
the doctor of Trinity is not this new
thing never before heard of that just
drops out of the sky right with with in
the fourth Century right after a long
period of development or anything else
and so
um you see this idea that the god of
Israel
has
more than one hypostasis more than one
person
right in reflected in the Old Testament
even though
it's not sort of narrowed down
completely in the mind of the writers of
the Old Testament text or even the
Jewish texts that come quote unquote in
between the Testaments they're all sort
of aware of this but how they work that
all out is very different
and so the son of man in in uh Daniel
uh is one sort of critically important
one and it's the one that becomes
Central
during that second temple period from
about the the fifth century BC to the
First Century A.D
um when you read Jewish literature
addressing it they're all coming back to
Daniel they're all coming back to the
son of man who who is this right because
this is clearly the second hypostasis
who is it where did he come from
right what what's happening
um so what Daniel does in that text is
he kind of remixes part of the bail
cycle
so in the culmination of the bail cycle
Bale is enthroned by his father l
um and
uh so the the depiction of the Ancient
of Days in Daniel is very clearly drawn
from
the way L was traditionally depicted
but the big remix happens with the son
of man
that it's not Baal it's not another God
who is now exalted himself to the
pantheon
when Daniel says it's one like a son of
man
it's it means this is a human right this
looks like a human to me right
um but he comes riding on the clouds
and the cloud rider was one of Bale's
titles because he was okay
and there are other parts of the Old
Testament
where that imagery gets picked up and
attributed to Yahweh
right so the the psalm we read in the
Orthodox Church at vespers
right at the beginning it talks about he
makes the clouds his chariot
he walks on the wings of the wind right
that's picking up that bail in the tree
and applying it to Yahweh later in that
same Psalm it talks about uh Leviathan
who he made to support in the waters
yeah and that's again a kind of a riff
because Bale defeated Leviathan that was
like his big claim to fame as I fought
and defeated this chaos Monster and that
depicts Yahweh like playing with him
like he's a pet like this is his puppy
or something yeah he doesn't have to
fight it it's like a little toy you know
um
so uh but here that imagery is all being
applied to this human
figure
right and because of the remixing of
Ellen Bale you have a father-son element
right brought in yeah okay in the
relationship of the two figures
um and you see this already in the
Jewish writers
yes for the New Testament that they're
that they have this father-son
discussion let's say yes okay yeah and
so for example in the latter portions of
the Book of Enoch the son of man is
explicitly identified as the Messiah
who is going to come
you have uh even when when this is
condemned eventually right in Jewish
circles we're getting Jewish circles in
the middle of the second century before
this
uh it was referred to as the idea of
there being two powers in heaven
and the word Powers there is ecstasia
that we often translate as Authority but
the idea is that
somebody who has ecstasia can operate
independently okay they're not under
anyone else's Authority right they're
not they're not depending yeah they're
not dependent like a soldier would be
dependent on a general or something
right right so the idea would be rather
than there just be there's God and then
the Angels obviously are under his
authority right all the other creative
beings are under his authority that
there are two in heaven
who operate with that kind of authority
and then there was there were different
ideas most of the major things we
consider trinitarian heresies from the
early church are really extensions of
those Jewish hypotheses into
Christianity
so there are Jewish sources in there who
say well this must be just like the
highest ranking angel
right and you find them using the same
text that the Aryans use later
right or Philo Philo is basically a
semi-arian he believed that the the
logos and wisdom
uh were sort of produced by God out of
his own Essence
right so you find these things that show
up in later Christianity within the
Jewish speculation
already beforehand but when it's
eventually condemned
um and the first records we have of this
on the talmud even though it happened in
the second century when Christians were
expelled from the synagogue yeah also
you think that so the idea is that when
the Christians were expelled from the
synagogue they also banned these types
of teachings these yes yeah and there's
a really good book by a Jewish scholar
Alan Sagel called two powers in heaven
that talks about this in the second
century
um and in the talmud there are two
different answers
this problem in different places so in
one place it talks about they have this
problem with Rabbi Akiva
who lived at the beginning of the second
century it was part of the barcode for
Rebellion he becomes this huge figure in
Judaism
but it was sort of well known that he
had believed in two powers in heaven
okay so in one of the track states of
the talmud they want to rehabilitate him
they say well yeah he thought that at
first
he got corrected yeah okay right yeah
the way it's phrased in the Talbot that
he got correct is that he later said uh
one is for mercy and one is for judgment
now that sounds obscure what that means
yeah but it's referring to the Thrones
that are set up in Daniel yeah the two I
mean you see those you see in Christian
iconography you see those two angels the
red and the Blue Angels yeah right the
two the two Thrones are set up and so
what is the extra days what is the son
of man right and so they say well Akiva
later said essentially a kind of
modalism
right that that God uh manifests himself
as an old man to show Mercy that is a
young man for rigor yeah yeah but they
made they brought it down to like the
the two hands or the the two sides I'd
say right interesting wow and then the
other explanation is is uh there's a
story that recounts this Rabbi who uh
through kind of merkava mysticism has
this vision of heaven and while he's
there he sees this Angel sitting down
right and so since he sees the angel
sitting down he says oh this angel must
have authority
and so he believes that the two powers
in heaven and then he's like sending to
Exile on the earth and condemned forever
and the angel gets uh flogged apparently
they're sitting down and it sat down on
a throne it's like that's the thing
people aren't used to they don't
understand the imagery of what it means
for someone to be sitting and someone to
be standing we do in the Orthodox church
we have a better sense of it because in
theory we stand in the church not much
anymore but yeah that at least was the
the original idea yeah yeah or
interesting stuff yeah so so even the
tell if it offers these two different
sort of resolutions to it right in terms
of
of who this figure was
because the figure also appears in
Ezekiel but in the in the merkaba itself
like is it yeah Ezekiel sees one right
as as a man right and so there's well
there's there's this tension all the way
through the Old Testament
so in the same chapter in Exodus at the
beginning of the chapter it talks about
Moses speaking to God face to face it
literally says mouth to mouth as a man
speaks to his friend
and then
a few verses later in the same chapter
Moses says oh I want to see your glory
and God says no you can't see it and
live
you're like well wait a minute right
they were
they were talking just to go up there
like what is happening right and and so
there's there's there's attention to the
Old Testament of no man could see God no
one could see God and live
and then there's all these stories of
people seeing God yeah
you know and Saint John takes that at
the end of the prologue to his gospel
says no one has seen God at any time
that's not a retcon of the Old Testament
like just forget all those stories
they're now not canon
but he said the second part of that is
but
either the unique God or the only
begotten God who is at the side of the
father has made him known so he's saying
it was this Divine son it was this
second figure who people were seeing all
through the Old Testament and the father
is the one who remained unseen but this
was already in there
right and this connection of him
particularly to
Humanity
right in a way that uh the extra days
was not right that the
the father was not right exactly and so
that in our that's in the Orthodox
tradition we have a very particular
preservation of that because it seems
like although
how can I say this the idea for example
that the CR that the man Jesus Christ
created the world for example you find
that in some in some text you see that
in Saint Maximus it has some crazy
sayings you know when while he was on
the cross he was creating the world like
all these types of contradictions but
for sure in the in the iconography it
was preserved very attentively so until
the 14th century you when you see God
represented anywhere in in the Old
Testament it's always Christ and so when
you see the creation of man you see
Christ and it's Jesus Christ right it's
it's it's not a it's like it's not the
pre-incarnate logos it's it's the man uh
Christ who is creating the world and it
seems like it's a it's a continuation of
that image
you know of the son of man the idea
would be something like although in
terms of time it doesn't make sense for
us but that automatically doesn't matter
the idea is that what they saw
what Daniel saw was Jesus Christ at the
side of God the Father
yeah yeah and
the the time problem is
is because of the type of creatures we
are
right we were talking you know we
mentioned Nago what is it like to be a
bat right animals don't experience time
the same way we do
right there are all different ways in
which their Consciousness is different I
was recently watching a thing about a
dog that had to have a leg amputated
and animals adapt to that kind of thing
almost instantly humans go through all
kinds of right because we have a
different kind of bodily awareness right
than an animal has
right so an animal's just I have three
legs now okay right yeah there's no
morning yeah
um so that includes the experience of
time
and so
uh we want to
apply our experience of time to for
example Angelic beings so this comes up
a lot with Lord of spirits stuff because
it's well when did the Angels Fall yeah
right it's sort of like well what time
is it in heaven right now like what time
zone are they on right
um
we're projecting right our experience
onto beings that are not like us whose
Consciousness is different than us I do
experience time in a different way and
there's this huge break point as soon as
you try to get to God yeah
right now you know and so time and space
are really
attributes of created things yeah
right and we've been taught in in
Western theology even right we talk
about omnipresence
you know well God's everywhere right it
created Things Early in one place at one
time but he's in all the places all the
time right that's not really what that
means right you read father dumitrus
Standalone is really good on this in his
Orthodox dogmatics right he has talks
about God's attributes being Supra
essential
so it's equally true to say God is
everywhere and to say that he's nowhere
yeah
right and that basically what we mean is
these spatial categories don't apply to
God
these uh temporal categories don't apply
to God when we say he's Eternal yeah
right and so when we talk about
um
Christ
before
yeah for the Incarnation the Incarnation
that's presuming that
Christ as God experiences time the way
we do
that there was this before and after and
over and over again in our dogmatics in
our hypnography and everything it talks
about how Christ took out our human
nature Christ we came in without change
or alteration yeah and I don't think we
take that seriously enough
yeah we we have this idea that that
because we say things like Christ
ascended into heaven and his and and his
body is there next to the father but we
now we think that that's in time it's
like well wait a minute
like yeah yeah and that was you know
sorry calvinist I gotta get one of these
in here right that was that was the
Calvinists it wasn't Calvin himself but
that was the calvinist whole argument
against Luther on the Eucharist was it
can't be Christ's body because Christ's
body is in heaven right yeah it's in
that place so it can't be all these
others
yeah yeah what's going on what's going
on yeah so there so there's an
interesting idea which is something like
when Christ ascended into heaven he
ascended into heaven from the beginning
like he ascended into heaven from
forever like from Beyond time let's say
like that there is no that he entered
into that it that that that Christ's
body is is in
is in God right it's not it doesn't it
doesn't it is not no longer it is not
yeah it's not limited by time or space
ultimately right it's not a question of
time and change that we experience yeah
there are points where these realities
enter into the realm of human
consciousness right
yeah that's the best way to explain it
there are points in in our history in
our human history where the fall of
certain Angelic beings entered into our
conscious experience
there's a place where Christ's
Incarnation entered into our conscious
experience but it's not that it wasn't
true before that yeah
right that's why he's the lamb slain
before the foundation of the world
yeah I've been quoting that verse a lot
these days
right I mean that's so that these things
are eternally true but they enter into
time and space right and our experience
in a particular way yeah
because of the type of beings that we
are
and so I want to I want to propose
something to you and I want to know what
you what you think about this because
I've one of the reasons why I've been
thinking about this question of the son
of man is because
we have this it's a technical problem
almost it's a technical problem right
now in terms of the transition into
people understanding the notion of
principalities or the notion of higher
forms of agency is that there's a sense
in which there's always
a difficulty or an ambiguity where
people will want to say well it's a
projection of the human psyche let's say
and you see that even in the Ancients
you'll find texts where they'll say are
the gods of creations of men you know or
or vice versa like what's the
relationship because the the gods are in
the image of man you could say and also
the things they manage like cities like
the aspects of reality that they manage
are related to us right so even in the
Greek in the in the the Greek uh idea
that of Poseidon like Poseidon is is the
god of the seas but he's it's always
related to how it affects troubles or
helps us as humans
um
and so what I've been thinking about is
it's there's a sense and you see that in
in The Narrative of scripture which is
something like although these angels are
above us
ultimately they are meant to serve us
that ultimately to the extent in which
we are in Christ who is the son of man
who is the Divine man then we will rule
over the angels and so it seemed to me
that the notion of The Heavenly Man the
son of man uh even if for people who
don't necessarily would even come to
believe that that's Jesus Christ let's
say who just have this idea of a
Heavenly Man or a man with a capital M
would be a solution to the technical
problem of agency above us is that it's
nearered through human man Consciousness
and so it the question of whether
they're projections of the psyche or
existing above us becomes mood in this
notion of a
Adam Cadman or you know Universal Man or
Heavenly Man as we find in in these kind
of traditions
yeah yeah well and that's
that's built into I mean Hebrew straight
out says that right that the the Angelic
Spirits were right created to to serve
us to minister to us
um but that's that's built into well
this is something we've lost this is
built into
what's going on in Genesis 3 with the
fall of the devil
because what you find when you read the
fathers closely if you get rid of Milton
right we don't need any Puritans
Milton's one of the better ones but we
don't need him either that's
um
but uh the devil fell all the fathers
have you know jealousy and envy
right and it's not jealousy or Envy of
God somehow
it's jealousy or Envy of humanity
yeah that's something that most people
don't think but it's definitely it's
there it's like it's weird because it's
there in the Islamic tradition too like
it's actually there's a story where
where the devil's asked to Bow before
Adam and then that's how he is cursed so
it seems like it was probably coming out
of these Christian Traditions at the
time too and it it it makes less sense
in Islam because they don't have Christ
like you were just talking about yeah
right because
the destiny of man is not just like you
know you're gonna stay a Corporal and
man's gonna humans are gonna be getting
made Sergeants
right he's going to get promoted over
you it's the destiny of Christ of being
united to God in a way that the angels
are not right as Hebrews again like
reiterates right
um and so
that is that is built in there but even
the language used by somebody like Plato
when he talks about the gods being
allotted their various places and and
things that they're in charge of he
describes them of shepherds
that they were appointed to Shepherd the
people and he says for a Time
they did it as gentle Shepherds and then
for him something changed for him
there's this Golden Age the age of
Cronus when that was true
and then after that things changed right
but he acknowledges that's not the way
it is now with the gods right and you
read Homer and you quickly see that's
not yeah they're feuding and fighting
with each other and switching sides in
battles and you know
um and so they've they've become they've
become something different if you read
eusebius's demonstration eusebius of
caesarea this demonstration of the
Gospel he sort of goes all in on this in
terms of this being what the gospel is
about it's about these Spirits
rebellious spirits who are assigned to
the Nations
and she talks about how they were
assigned to lead and he's picking up on
Saint dionysius here too they were
assigned to lead the Nations to God like
right to lead them to Christ but they
did not they LED them somewhere else and
so now new Spirits like the Saints right
are now replacing them who will lead
right Humanity to God and to Salvation
to becoming like God
right and
um to sort of accomplish that
that Destiny so it's not just leap
frogging in a hierarchy that's set up
artificially yeah it's an ontological
difference
yeah and so man so man as this point you
could say this anchor between the
visible created world and the invisible
has an advantage ultimately
you know because all the the Pinnacle of
that would be Christ you could say the
Pinnacle of that connection would be
Christ and and then that Center becomes
has an advantage over the incorporable
beings even because it it kind of spans
all the hierarchy itself right so the
the you read the celestial hierarchies
of Saint dionysius right and
the these aren't like races of or
species of angels right that look
certain ways because they don't
reproduce right that's not the idea is
they have different jobs they have
different tasks right that they're
performing in these different
ranks and
uh the higher the rank
as it's described the closer they are to
the throne of God
and so the more they participate in the
grace of God because God empowers them
to fulfill sort of their job assignment
their role that he created them to play
right but Angels don't get like promoted
up that ladder
it's not like well you did a really good
job as an angel we're going to try you
out as an archangel see how you do right
like
you know maybe you'll be a throne
someday right like that's not how it
right how it works they have this job
whereas Humanity because in Christ
our shared human nature is perfectly
United to God
right in Christ the person of Christ
because of that Humanity can make
infinite progress
in the grace of God toward God there's a
potentially infinite because the
distance is infinite between God and any
creature we can make infinite progress
toward God which is something the
Angelic Powers can't do
and that invoke jealousy in some of them
and add rebellion in some of them
and so
what's interesting what's interesting uh
to me especially like this this it's a
this Doctrine or this notion is that in
some ways it makes sense of creation
I've always
thought that that the notion of the OSIS
ex helps us understand the reason for
creation because I remember when I was
younger I was told something like you
know
God created us for us to submit to him
and and glorify like that's our job like
we're there so God creates the world and
the world is there to worship him
basically there's something I mean there
was something unsatisfying about that
yeah like really God creates so God
creates the world to worship him I I
guess I mean I mean he is God so he he
deserves it I'm saying that I want to
take away from God but the notion that
there's rather this
it's almost like a love
let's say a
it's like it's almost like a love story
you know where God creates the human
person in order to then bring the human
person back into him to the extent that
that that's possible like that that that
seems like a much more and that we do
the same with creation we could say that
it's also kind of our job to do that
with creation it makes just makes it a
far more beautiful story to me that
that's it's God's love
yeah he has no needs but out of love he
created Humanity to share his life with
to share his Divine Life with and this
undergirds
in the Old Testament all of the language
of Israel as sort of his wife and then
the language of the church is the bride
of Christ
because we have to go back to the social
structures of the time
right which where a man would become
established
right he would create a life for himself
right he would have a life he would have
property he'd have right a place and
then he would marry a woman and bring
her into that
and then they would have children right
and those children would share they
would share that life together
right and so he's using that cultural
imagery to explain right God has created
this world right he has this life in
himself
and he creates humans and brings them in
to share it with them and so it's not
God demands worship if you refuse he's
going to be very angry at you
and torment you eternally for it right
it's God created you out of love he's
extending that love to you he wants to
share his life with you but he also
leaves you free
right there's a right of consent he
leaves you free to reject that
if you want to and cut yourself off from
it if you want to
right which is a very different picture
and so where do you because this has
been I guess like there's a there's
there's you guys talking about this in
terms of the the this different vision
of well I guess it's a it's also in some
ways a restoration after the materialism
we've been through this vision of divine
Council you know this idea of these
hierarchies of intelligences all of this
a lot of people are going back to that
people always quote Michael Heiser but
even even people that are kind of in
completely on other tangents I've
noticed that that David Bentley heart
has been going at that too you know
saying saying basically Paul is talking
about angels like he's called all Paul's
talking about his angels all the time
and people seem to have forgotten that
uh so so
it seems like this is to give me your
impression of this because it seems like
there is we were talking about this idea
of re-enchantment there's this there's
this moment of re-enchantment but it
seems to me that there's a that the
re-enchantment isn't always
good let's say that although this moment
in in the breakdown of materialism is
offering us the possibility of of seeing
these Mysteries once again it's also
a space of flooding in of of all these
demons basically that the demons are
flooding in too so I don't know if
that's something that you've noticed or
that you've thought about in terms of
the the current moment
well
I I I don't think they ever actually
went away
I don't think closing our eyes and
pretending they weren't there
you know you look at the history of mass
murder and genocide in the 20th century
all over the world they were there and I
don't think pretending there weren't any
Spirits really protected us rather than
if anything the opposite
right there were Spirits at work in
different places at different times
moving people in masses of people right
um
so in one way I think just being aware
is better than being in denial right of
the reality the the problem is I think
so
we've lost sort of a spiritual
technology you might say a spiritual
technique know-how that we used to have
right that because we understood these
things so we understood when we sensed
that there was this malign Spirit at
work in a group in a place right in a
nation or something we sort of knew how
to exercise it and how to invite in
another better one
right and you see this as the as the
Roman Empire was christianized right
they acted this out very literally you
know Saint Cyril of Alexandria taking
the bodies of Martyrs and having them
reburied where Pagan temples used to be
um this was very much very much acted
out and I think we've we've lost that
know-how is our biggest problem even as
we're becoming aware
right we may become aware like there's
something wrong here there's something
you know there's a spirit moving this is
right but we don't know how to make that
switch
and that's even true I mean just to take
a particular case
that we mentioned recently our lord of
spirits with technology yeah right with
with technology this has been true
throughout history every time we first
discover something our first use for it
is pretty much evil
right so we learned how to split the
atom make a bow right and and the second
atomic bomb that gets dropped wipes out
more than 50 percent of the Christians
in Japan in Nagasaki it was the most
Christian City in Japan before
more than half of the Christian
population of Japan was there wiped out
right by a bomb
um
the internet
I don't remember how old you are but I
was there back in the old days when it
first started and it was mostly
pornography right away yeah right that's
the pornography distribution system
um and now
social media
right like and all of these things our
first use for them is evil but we used
to know down the road
how to make the move right how to banish
the spirit that was
you know that maybe helped us find the
technology before we were ready for it
and how to then put it to a better use
and now I don't think we know how to do
that anymore
um
yeah because that narrative is there
this is something I've been reflecting
on quite a bit it's there very much in
scripture you have a sense in which even
in the Bible
you know even without looking at the
extra biblical Traditions you have a
sense in which technology comes in with
the fall of Cain and Kane's descendants
are the ones the ones that develop
technology and that brings us down to
the flood but then you have a sense in
which the ark is also a technology and
that it covers you could say
Keynes technology right it becomes it
raises it up and becomes a vehicle for
preservation through the through the
flood and then you see the same with the
question of the temple and the
Tabernacle and the temple like you know
it it's um I think it's bezalel when the
when he's named as one of the ones who
who uh creates the Tabernacle it's his
name he sounds like the darkness of God
and then he's called an artificer which
is the only other place in the Bible
where that word is used except for tubal
cane so it's like they're clearly
linking him to tubal Kane but basically
saying like we're going to redeem this
process you know uh and if you add the
enokian Traditions into that then it
becomes even clear that there's a a
sense in which this taking of that's
like reaching up and grabbing a pattern
of reality and then pulling it down into
the world you can see that as having sex
with a having sex with this with the
demon like you but different ways to
image that right but it's like you take
from above and you bring it into
yourself and then usually the the result
of that is a giant it's a it's like a
it's it's a giant body that is very
powerful that destroys uh and and it's
like this and it's say it's as if people
have forgotten that and now it's so out
of control you think that technological
progress is a good in itself which is
just the craziest thing in the world to
think that but that's well I mean
you look at American politics right you
have we have two parties one of which is
just completely technocratic
neoliberalism technology will solve all
our problems and the other one is
technology drives the free market
and so it's good for Commerce so it's
good right so there's no there's no sort
of dissent on the technological
innovation will will always be good
we'll always move in a positive
direction yeah but even though now
there's this awareness more awareness
coming
awareness without the tools to do
something about it
just causes everybody to get black pills
right realize how horrible everything is
just you just lay down and and sleep
that's
um you know and I mean really so if I
mean if you're in a form of Christianity
that doesn't have any relics you can't
go bury them in the Pagan Temple yeah
right if you don't have any holy water
you can't come and and bless your house
right if you don't have right and so
even our Christian practice
and this isn't just a pitch for the
Orthodox church right because there are
other churches who do have some of these
things and there are a lot of people at
the Orthodox Church especially in North
America who are practicing
in a very materialistic way shall we say
um
but
we've lost a lot of those tools or at
least we think or we think you know the
priest's coming to bless the house is
just like a nice thing he does when he
comes and visits once a year yeah they
don't see it as as a as a the
manifestation of authority over
over something like a pattern that's
there it's like installing a new pattern
of authority which comes from God and is
and is brought into the into the the
place that's
and and it makes like it's I always try
to translate this stuff for secularists
so they can kind of understand why
sprinkling holy water would change
something and it has specifically to do
with the idea that if you have a pattern
that is out of control and it has a life
of its own then you need Authority in
order to change it you can't just change
it it you can't there's no way to just
change things without something else
taking its place or Another Story
Another Vision another another pattern
coming in and taking its place and
that's that's that that means ritual it
means it means Authority it means actual
action right it's not something that
just happens in your mind it has to be
played out in the body as well of the
place so it's not this isn't like just
mumbo jumbo
because I know that a lot of people will
listen and think well this is just mumbo
jumbo like why would sprinkling water on
something make it make change it and
because because of because patterns
change with authority that's how it
works right well and
part of this is
um
uh confession I watched part of you
talking to Douglas Murray and got super
frustrated about this and stop
um
the guy is too Protestant to be a
Christian
um he's
the the
the idea that we have that's what Been
bequeathed To Us by particularly Puritan
protestantism that that what's important
is ideas
and that ideas precede practice
has broken all of this for us yeah we
have this idea well you have these
theological ideas
what makes you a Christian is that you
accept that they're true so if I gave
you a true false test you'd put the t's
and F's in the right places right now
you're a Christian because you believe
that these certain things are true yeah
and then you come up with practices to
reflect your beliefs right and that's
exactly backwards
right that but ideas and beliefs emerge
from practice
emerge from a way of life
right and a way of being in the world
right and so I mean if you took a time
machine back to ancient Athens
and said to them so you believe there's
12 people up on this mountain like we
could go there right now right you
wouldn't find them and they govern all
of human Destiny and they right you
actually believe that that's they look
at you like you were crazy yeah that's
right
right because that's not what it meant
to be at a theater it was to hold
certain beliefs
right what it meant to be an Athenian
was to have a connection to that piece
of ground that your family had worked
for Generations outside Athens right and
that Athens was the center of your
social and political life
right and part of that was the worship
of these particular Gods at the United
faced us right and all of this but all
of that emerged and so they would if
they were able to answer you they would
say well no you need to move here
and you need to come and share our life
right and you need to live the way we
live participate in our festivals
participate yeah and then then one day
you'll be able to see the gods you'll
understand yeah you'll understand what
all this is about yeah right you'll
understand what all this is about and
this is this is a problem with the way a
lot of Orthodox churches do catechesis
because
the way we do catechesis is well here's
the dates of the ecumenical councils and
here's the Orthodox Church believes this
and this and this and we try to convince
people outside the Orthodox church or
outside of Christianity to believe that
this is true
right whereas what we need to be doing
is and what I try to do at least is even
if a guy shows up and he's like I've
read this giant stack of books on the
Orthodox faith and I've watched every
symbolic World video and I'm on board I
agree 100 with everything right
I'm still gonna make him attend the
church for a year yeah I become part of
the community and start fasting and
feasting with us and getting to know
everyone and all that because even those
things that he says he accepts now
will he will relate to in a different
way at the end of that year
right and so
that that way of life right the idea
that ideas emerge from that and they
make sense in that context we do this
with the moral teaching of the church
all the time too
you try to throw the moral teaching of
the Church of people who are completely
outside the church we're in a context
where it doesn't make sense well why
can't I do that
right and it's like well there's a
thousand things that would make sense to
you if you were relating to the world in
a different way yeah right and so yeah
from outside throwing bee throwing a
bunch of water around your house trying
not to ruin any Electronics right does
it look like this would be beneficial to
you in any way right
but it becomes meaningful within a
context of relationships
right and a way of living and being in
the world
right that that person doesn't share yet
and so it's not going to make total
sense to them yet
yeah that makes a lot of sense
well father thanks thanks for your time
this was a great discussion and uh as if
there are still people watching this
that don't listen to the Lord of spirits
you have to check it out and also don't
forget father Stephen also has are you
still writing your your your uh your uh
Council uh hold Council of God blog as
well are you still there there hasn't
there hasn't been anything recently I've
been focusing on books yeah but there
will be sporadic things but it's still
there yeah it's still there you can find
a Blog book review a few months ago so
and and get and get the book for sure so
so so we will definitely I mean I'm sure
we will have other chances of of uh
having a conversation and I hope one day
I'll be able to meet you in person that
would be nice because this Zoom thing is
at some point it we have to move into
real spaces yeah
absolutely oh thank you Father thank you
John